- That would make me
less mad about traffic.
Welcome, Bobby.
- Thank, thank you.
- Thanks so much for being here.
Bobby is the interior
designer extraordinaire
on Netflix hit show Queer Eye.
Today, we have some audience questions
on how to make their spaces better.
- Thanks for sending these in, guys.
I won't be too harsh.
- Hello, my name is Abby.
I am in my craft room right now.
- I would love help making my craft room
feel more creative and inspiring.
What I would recommend is paint
something cool on the wall.
If you're not a good
painter, do a geometric.
You know, squares, circles, triangles,
those are always very easy.
Doing cool, bright colors,
I think that would definitely
make it feel more inspiring
and more of a creative space.
- I like that!
- Hi, guys.
My name's Rebecca.
- This random room in our house
has a fabulous view of our backyard,
but nothing we do with it sticks.
Now it's just extra space
for our new baby stuff.
It also opens up to our backyard
where we let the dog out.
So, bedroom is not the best option.
If it has space for the outdoors,
definitely make it a space
where you can appreciate
the view of the outdoors.
Put a nice little sofa or chair,
make it a little reading room maybe.
- Add a little bar cart.
- Yeah, definitely
for a nice little martini in
the afternoon and a good read.
- My husband and I just
moved into our own place
and it's a basement.
- And I would like some tips
on making it feel more homey,
less 70s, and not feel as dark.
I actually like the room.
I think it looks groovy,
but if you're wanting
it to not feel so dark,
I would paint the walls white.
It will really open up the space.
Maybe keep the bar there, though,
so that way it adds a
little bit of depth to it.
As Johnathan would say, meow!
- Hi, friends, I'm Natalie,
and my interior design question
is about maximizing the
space I have in my kitchen
slash dining area that's
all kind of one thing.
I would probably do mounted
cabinets up on the upper walls
so that way you can still
sit at the dining table,
but you have upper storage.
It'll actually make the room feel larger
'cause it'll draw your eye up.
- I live in a university residence.
All of our rooms look
like ugly jail cells.
- Looking for ways to brighten my room
and make it feel like home.
My advice in dorms is removable wallpaper
because most dorms I
know won't let you paint.
It's a good way to give
it some personality,
make it feel more like home
without getting in
trouble with the school.
- I wanna maximize my space
so I can have friends come over and visit.
- The problem is it's a micro-efficiency
measuring under 150 square feet, tiny.
- You can always have
friends over, though.
- I would move the desk over
a little more towards the bed
and it will double as a
desk and a night stand,
and then under that window,
I would do a storage bench
with a cushion on top.
And that way it adds
storage in your small place,
but it also makes for basically
a sofa over in the corner.
- I love that.
- My name is Bailey.
Thank you so much for taking the time
to listen to my sad decorating woes.
- I have always been bad at decorating
or knowing anything about how
to make a house or a home.
The only thing I refuse to
take down is my Irish flag,
but please, for the love of
all that is holy, please help.
I would actually hang
the flag over the bed,
kind of make it as a headboard.
Get some bedding that
coordinates with the flag.
If you're gonna go for it, go for it.
Make it a theme.
- Go full Irish.
- A good old Irish theme.
- Yeah, I feel like every
time I get new bedding,
it makes me just feel
happier and refreshed.
- Bedding is something
you should splurge on.
You wanna wake up feelin' happy.
You wanna go to bed feeling happy.
Spend a little extra
money on good bedding.
Don't be fooled by the
whole thread count thing,
it's not real.
- Really?
- It's an American marketing ploy.
(gasps)
- If it feels good, it's good.
If it doesn't feel nice,
no matter how many thread
count or how expensive it is,
it's not nice.
- So, that's it.
Thank you so much
for stopping by.
- Of course, no, it was fun.
- Where can people follow
you on your socials?
- You can follow me @bobbyberk
on Instagram or Twitter.
- Be sure to check out Bobby
and let us know if you
have any more questions.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.